Friday's been kind of hard.
It's been a stressful day of work,
and I've spent the last like, um, 30 minutes just trying
to decompress from what's happened.
So it's okay. Not every day is good.
Some days are hard, but it's good that we're here.
Uh, we get study the work together.
Um, we get to look at how good our God is
and, um, examine, uh, Jesus in
a new way tonight that allows us
to just worship him even more.
So, let's go ahead and pray as we get started.
Uh, focus our hearts. Some. We're gonna learn tonight.
Lord God, we love you.
We are still, um, so grateful,
uh, for your desire for us.
We're thankful for the salvation that we have.
And you, we love, uh,
the salvation that you've given to us, that we are sinners
and we bring nothing to the table.
And yet you are gracious and you are good.
It's you. Make a way for us to be called your sons
and daughters and eternally be in your family.
God, we, uh, we invite your spirit.
Not that you need our invitation, you can work as, uh,
as you please, but we invite you to come.
We ask that you will come
and your spirit will, um, speak to us tonight
as we examine your word, as you reveal things to us, uh,
uh, in our own hearts, in our own lives.
Uh, reveal things through the experience in the world
around us, and shape those thoughts
and those experiences by your word to see you more rightly
and to glorify your son Jesus.
That's our prayer. We love you
and your son's gonna
pray well.
Just a couple matters of housekeeping.
Thanksgiving is next week.
I know that caught me by supplies today
when I looked at the calendar.
Can't believe that this already next week.
Uh, so we will, uh, we'll not have, uh, our class next week.
We'll be closed on Wednesday for Thanksgiving.
So, um, hopefully get some time celebrating
with some loved ones and friends on Thanksgiving next week.
Get some time of rest. Uh, mark, I believe the week
after that we will be meeting as a recap for this semester.
Is that fair? In our last official meeting in here. Okay.
For the seminary students. We'll have one more online. Okay.
So next, not next week, but the week after.
We'll be back here, uh, to recap
what we've learned over this semester,
but just a recap of what we've learned so far.
Um, so going back to August when we started,
um, we've, we've gone through several, um, doctrines.
We've looked in depth these doctrines over the course
of several weeks, just as a reminder of things
that we've examined in here together.
We've studied the doctrine of the word of God.
We've studied the doctrine of who God is, uh, his existence,
his no ability, his attributes, his communicable
and incommunicable attributes.
And we've looked at the doctrine of the trinity Together.
We've examined the works of God and his creation
and his providence.
We've looked at the works of God and his miracles.
Uh, we've looked at prayer.
Steve led us that night, uh,
angelic beings in spiritual realm.
I remember Jacob meeting us
through a discussion at the end of that.
And then over the last two weeks,
we looked at the doctrine of man.
Trevor led one week.
And then we looked last week at what, uh, what it means
to be male and female and how that applies to us
as image bearers of God.
So all of that framework that we've studied together so far
this semester brings us to the night
where we're gonna study the doctrine of sin.
So having spent the last several weeks examining the
holiness of God, we looked at how the glory
of Yahweh is on display and his creation.
And then specifically over these last two weeks,
we were able to discuss at the link God's intention
for his glory and his wisdom to be on display in humans
as his image bearers.
That all brings us to tonight.
So why do you think, just as an intro question
to tonight's topic, why do you think it's necessary, uh,
to have a solid understanding of those subjects
that we've looked at so far this semester?
His word, who got it, his, his works on display.
Why is it good to have a solid understanding
of those subjects before we study the concept
of sin and its consequences?
What do you think what you got?
'cause sin, basically, whenever we go
against God's intention
Way That he work, that
is God's intentions against his design.
What else is it important
Puts us in our rightful place?
Yeah, that's good. Let's elaborate on that.
What, what is our rightful place? What do we mean by that?
We aren't God, I heard something. We aren't God.
Yeah. That we aren't God. It's good.
Have a solid understanding of who God is
and how other he is from us.
It's good.
Anything else? Understanding his own.
And it helps his understand sin better when we think,
when we understand who He's and how perfect He's,
and it's, you know, it's just a,
Yeah.
Yeah. It's, it's kind of establishing that standard.
Like we don't have the standard to look at.
It's really hard to build any sort of framework around that.
Right. Other thoughts?
I mean, you should want to, if you love something,
you should want know as much as you possibly can.
That's true. Yeah. Yeah. Hopefully you guys have seen that.
I know I've seen that over the last few
weeks studying this together.
Um, the more we look at God
and the more we, um, take in who he is
and what he's done, our love
and our adoration for him grows.
Right? And that's good to have that love
and adoration for God before we look at this concept of sin.
'cause it helps ground us
and what, um, what the good standard is, right?
What to look forward to. Yeah.
Although God and his holiness
and wisdom, as we've seen, created a perfectly good universe
that was designed to reflect
and share his glory, what we'll see tonight is
that his created image bearers as well as some angels.
We don't want to disregard that fact,
but, um, us
as his image bearers rejected his design and authority.
And we choose to be like God by the fit,
by defining wisdom for ourselves.
In essence, that's what we're gonna be looking at tonight.
When we look at the concept of sin at its core.
That's, that's what it is.
And the study tonight, um, sin from its definition,
how do we define sin?
We'll put some framework around that.
We'll look at how sin plays out in its nature
and in our nature, and then we'll look at the results,
the consequences, uh, the punishment for sin.
Our, uh, key verse for tonight is Romans five 12.
I think you have that, uh, on your card.
So let's, let's read that together tonight
as someone read Romans five 12 for us.
Therefore, just the sin came into the world
through one man and death through sin.
And so death spread to all men, because all sin.
Yeah. We're gonna look at this in
depth in just a little bit.
Um, and really what the, what the real meaning
behind this verse is.
And we'll see it in context too as we look together tonight.
But let's take a step back from there.
So sin, if you just think about it, sin is not a word
that we just use in common language outside
of Christian biblical culture, right?
At work. If someone, you know, steals
and takes credit for something that you produce,
it's not like you go to your boss
and say, man, Tommy over here really sinned against me
by stealing my work.
You know, it's not just that, it's not a common word
that we use in our everyday language.
So if you were to go out, let's say you went out
to the street and you did this whole, um, family feud stuff,
hold a hundred people, uh, well,
how do you think they would answer the question?
What is sim just a hundred, a hundred brand new people?
What do you think they would say?
Disobedience to God. Disobedience to God? Yeah.
Things like murder. Yeah, murder.
Anything Just generally bad.
Just I would say most people
of probably don't think too much of like sin.
What a very generic answer. Just tell them that.
Yeah. Doing bad ways. Right? That's good.
What do you think, what sins are seen as the worst
by humans across the world,
or maybe even throughout history?
What do you think people generally say?
These are just, that's the worst kind
Type of state. Murder,
Murder, that one's pretty universally, right?
Harming children. Harming children.
What else? Anything else? Make that top list
That, That stealing?
Yeah, I think if you were to ask most people, they would,
their framework around sand would revolve
around kind of those things, right?
Really bad things.
Um, But we are,
we're gonna look at sin tonight from a biblical standpoint.
So get a better idea, better definition of
what sin truly is.
Gda, in the book, we've been studying to find sin
as any failure to conform to the moral law of God
and act attitude or nature.
So if we, if we look at that definition that he provides,
there's a few assumptions that, um, we can
derive from that definition.
The first assumption that we could derive is
that God sits in the seat of authority to define
what is good and what is not good.
So if we say the moral law of God, that assumes
that God is the one who is defining
what is good and what is not good.
But there's assumptions that go beyond that.
We assume that as the creator of all things
and the origin of all things, that anything
and everything that God does is good.
It's not just good or not good
because he declared it to be good.
Like he wrote it down as a list.
It's because He, whatever he does, anything
and everything that he does by nature is good.
Going a little bit further than that, we would assume
that anything and everything
that exists in God's nature is good just by matter
of existence.
If God is the origin of all things,
just everything in His nature is essentially good
because he is from what everything comes from.
The next assumption that we could make from that is
that if there is a, that there is a moral law,
and that moral law exists because God exists.
This is an important distinction to make, that, um,
a moral law was not created by God.
It's not something that he came up with.
It simply exists because God exists.
If God exists, there is a moral law.
Because everything that God does, everything that He is,
is the moral law of what is the standard of what
that moral law is.
They are the moral law is not rules
or laws that God has created and could
therefore alter recklessly.
But they're instead immutable, dependable qualities
of his nature reflected in our universe.
They exist because God exists, not because God created them
or recognized them later.
This moral law is absolutely true
and fundamental to reality.
The next assumption that we could derive in is
that God's will defines what is morally good.
If it is in God's will,
and God will something to be that it is morally good if
as it is with God's will.
On the surface, that sounds easy and of course,
but we'll see some situations where that is hard
and it's hard to reckon with.
The next assumption that we can make is that anything
outside of God's will is morally wrong.
And then the last assumption is God's will.
That humanity follows his design for life
and relationship with him and with others.
And so if we've assumed
before that God's will is morally good, anything that falls
outside of his will
and his design for humanity is in essence morally wrong.
So Gruden goes on to explain that sin, when examined
by this definition, presents itself in three ways.
And action. That would be the things that we do.
These are the behavioral things.
A lot of the examples we came up with, stealing, murder,
lying, gossip, cheating, but not just in action
or behavior, but it presents itself in attitude.
This would be the things that we desire, envy, covetousness,
hatred, lust, selfishness.
And then also sin presents itself in moral nature.
So the internal character
or essence of who we are as persons,
we see this in scripture.
Just a couple of brief comments,
and we'll get into this a little bit more later.
Ephesians two, three.
Paul states, we were by nature children of wr.
He says, again, in Romans five, eight, while we were
yet sinners, Christ died for us.
It's not, he doesn't use the term why we were yet sinning
as if it was just based on our actions.
But he talks about the essence of actually who we are,
defined as sinners.
Christ died for us.
So these three, if we look at sin from those three angles,
they help to build a frame, a framework
for understanding the full scope of sin.
But Ultimately, we haven't really talked about
what is sin at its core.
We've kind of said it shows up in these in these ways.
But ultimately, what is sin at its core?
I just ask this question to you all.
Do you believe that there's an underlying thread
that weave into the fabric of all sin?
Do you see one or do you have ideas of what
that might look like?
It's putting our will above God's will.
That's a good, that's really Good answer.
The will above God's will.
I'm trying to think of, you know,
how Jesus says like he's the life I think of it,
sin is the absence of life sense.
Yeah. Because if God himself is light anything outside
of God,
let me ask you a question.
Might go back a couple weeks on this one,
but what is the chief end of me?
Glorify God, Glorify God,
Enjoy him, Enjoy it, and enjoy him eternally.
Yeah. So going back a couple weeks, when Trevor led us,
we looked at how humans were designed as image bearers,
but we were designed ultimately to worship.
Truthfully, all of creation is, is designed to worship God,
but specifically humans were designed to worship.
And we weren't just designed to worship anything.
We were designed to worship God
that created both individually
and then us, also collectively as a species
or to ate together, bear his image and worship him.
We are designed in this way.
But if man will not worship godly creator,
what do you think fills that vacuum of adoration
that we were designed to express?
So in other words, ask a simple, simple way.
If we don't worship God, are we gonna worship something
Safe?
I heard some answers say, say yeah, ourselves.
Yeah. It's kind of like, um,
I'm thinking a really bad analogy.
Um, a car is designed to drive, right?
That's what it's made to do. We are designed to worship.
We're made to worship.
So just
because we're not going, if we don't worship God,
we're gonna still be worshiping by design.
That's what we're designed to do.
So inescapably man will worship something in God's place.
What's the, what's the Christian ease, the biblical word
that we, that we know that to be
and we worship something else other than God.
Idol. Idol idolatry. Yeah.
I would say that idolatry is ultimately that thread
that weaves through all of sin.
John Piper describes as any feeling or thought
or speech or action that comes from a heart
that does not treasure God over all things.
Let's look at this in scripture
and see how Paul plays this out a little bit.
Will you turn with me to Romans one?
We're gonna start in verse 18.
We're gonna read Romans one 18 through 21.
Does someone read that for us? Romans one 18 through 21,
The WR of God revealed,
condemn against the all ungodliness
and un of them, provide their un the truth
for what can be known about God.
That's plain to them because God has shown it to them
for his invisible attributes, mainly his eternal power.
Divine nature have been clearly perceived
ever since the creation of the world
and the things that have been made.
So they are without excuse for
although they knew God.
They did, they did not honor him as God
or give thanks to him,
but they became futile in their thinking
and their foolish hearts were darkened.
Yeah, this is a pretty powerful accusation
and explanation that Paul makes of the human condition.
It explains a lot of
why we see the world the way that it is.
But ultimately, what Paul explains here is that men,
mankind at least suppress the truth.
Because what can be known about God is plain to them.
We talked about this, about those, uh, attributes of God,
some of those being globally visible about God,
but also his moral law is visible
and experienced by us as humans.
And he says that although they knew God,
they did not glorify him as God or give thanks to him.
So ultimately, when he's saying that there's this root
of suppressing the truth about God
and suppressing that desire to basically
to avoid giving him glory things,
that is what's going on in the human condition, is that we,
even though we know the truth, or we knew about who God is
and who were designed to worship, we suppress that truth.
To avoid giving him glory
going on in Romans one, will summon read 22 and 23
To be wisest.
God.
Yeah. So remember that.
If man's not going to glorify God,
if man's not gonna worship God, we're going
to worship something in his place.
And what does Paul say here?
That man, if they're not worshiping God turns to worship.
Creation. Creation. Yeah.
We worship things in the creatures instead of the creator.
We worship things created instead of the origin, the creator
of all things God.
The result of that simple nature idol
who plays itself out in many shapes and forms.
We've seen that throughout the history of humanity.
But all of those vice,
whether it's the ancient Egyptians worshiping raw,
the Sun God, or us worshiping ourselves
through these devices that we use,
they all boil down to the same basic fact that sin
hates and suppresses the truth of God
and it exchanges it for what sin loves and worships.
Sin loves to worship
and serve the creature, not the creator.
So when we reject the truth that God is the one
and only king who deserves our worship and our adoration,
and when we live as worshipers designed
to live in submission to his, to his lives.
And perfect rule, when we live in that way, instead of
how we're designed, we sin, we live in sin.
So explain this corruption that we see to explain further
what sin is, this corruption of God's perfect design.
The biblical authors have used a myriad of different ways
to, to show this, but they use, um,
three terms very often to explain what sin is.
They use language, um, like sin,
iniquity, and transgression.
If you look throughout scripture,
those three words are used over and over
and over again to explain this condition
of sin that we've been talking about.
So I want us to spend a little bit of time examining each
of one of those words and how they're used in scripture
and how it helps eliminate, um, a little bit better what,
what we're talking about when we say the word saying.
So the first one of those to illustrate this word.
Um, let's do
This.
Who's to, who's to shoot a shot here?
Mark, you start us up. Alright, all. Can you make this?
If you, you make it. You read my illustration. Oh, okay.
So Don't try No, try your best.
That's Pretty good. What you got, man?
Hello? Oh,
Let's Start sweat, man.
All right, one more. David, you guys.
Okay. I would say all three
of you guys are pretty good errands
Close.
But ultimately, while those were close, none
of 'em actually hate.
Right? What would we call that?
Missing? The Mark. Missing the mark. Yeah.
You've probably heard this, this term, this explanation.
So that is the English word sent.
The Hebrew word for that is qta,
and the Greek word is Tia.
But all three of those words,
whether we use the English word sin
or we use the Hebrew word as the biblical author said,
or the Greek word hamartia.
Ultimately what it means is to fail
to miss the mark, to miss the goal.
Um, that word, uh, is not always used in reference
to like moral sin.
In, in scripture in judges 2016, that saying word is used
to describe how an expert with a, with a sling, um,
could sling a stone
and not, not miss the mark, not miss the bullseye.
It's the same word that's used in Proverbs 19 two, uh,
when the, uh, proverbs says that we, that people
who act hastily while traveling are likely
to Qatar are likely to miss their intended destination.
So that brings us to the, the question then.
So if sin is missing a goal
or missing the mark, what is that goal?
What's the goal?
Perfection. Perfection. Yeah, that's good.
Let's elaborate on that.
Righteousness. Righteousness. Yeah.
Ob Obedience. Be call. Yeah.
Be light like Jesus. Yeah.
Yeah. Pretty high standard, right?
So even though Aaron hit the rim of the pitcher,
it wasn't ultimately making the goal, right?
It wasn't the actual thing.
Sin doesn't mean that we are or to, to not miss the goal.
Doesn't mean that we are God,
but we are living according to his design.
We exist according to his design.
Ultimately, that plays itself out in how we love him
and respond to him.
How we love one another perfectly.
That's what God's design for humanity was.
So let's look at the second word.
So we've looked at the most common one. Sin.
The second word that's used often in scripture is
this word in Nick way.
And if you're like me,
you probably never use the word iniquity just in like
everyday language, right?
So what does this word iniquity mean?
So English word iniquity, the Hebrew word would be Avon Vo
not Hebrew.
Speaker.
Make. Huh?
Makeup.
Makeup, no.
But now that I know the Hebrew meaning of this word,
that seems kind of funny.
So ultimately what this word means,
and the verb tense would be to aah,
but it implies
something that was straight, but is now bent.
Another way we could say would be bent or crooked,
or even it,
I didn't make it home before I came over here tonight,
but the illustration I wanted to show
for this would be if you were to take a,
let's say a paper towel tube, right?
And you were to shine a light through that tube,
you would be able to see the light on the other side.
But as soon as you bend that tube, you shine the light
through that there would be no visible light
in even from this side.
'cause now that pad is bent, it's crippled.
So something that is used to describe that as bent, crooked,
or twisted as an enc crooked road.
The scriptures also use this word to describe a back
that is bent out of shape in a physical sense.
But it implies a distorting of what, uh, what was
otherwise beautiful or good.
And it's something that is twisting, that something
that was good or beautiful
and is something that is ugly and evil.
Instead of being fruitful
and multiplying, we see murder and death.
Instead of caring for the poor, we see instead envy
and stealing from our neighbor instead
of submitting to one another.
And love, we see things like lust
and using others for our own pleasure.
The word is also used to refer not just to the action,
the crooked or bent actions, but also the crooked
and bent results of our actions of our sin.
It's used iniquity is used
to describe things like suffering people.
It's used to describe shattered relationships.
It's used to describe, uh, violence amongst nations.
So when we hear the biblical phrase
to bear your iniquity, this is what that is.
That term often is foreign to us.
What does it mean to bear your iniquity?
It means burying God allows mankind to carry the weight
of their own crooked vent and twisted choices.
That's what that means to bear your nuclear.
So when you think about understanding sin as the twisting
or the bending of what God intended to be straight, How does
that help you to see
and understand the consequences of sin more clearly?
What do you think?
How does understanding sin as bending
or twisting God's intended design or humanity
and creation allow you to understand its consequences?
Its results. It's pretty easy to look at the world
and see the,
so those price makes are pass straight and then for that.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yeah. That's good.
Well, if you gave me example of a paper towel mm-hmm.
Think you had a gun that's bent,
it might either blow up on you, right?
Yeah. Or it's at loose in shoot my shoot
Skirt. Yeah. Not shoot
street. Yeah.
Even slightly, slightly off. True. Right
Down down range.
Yeah. It kind of comes back to the illustration that
John was using with the plumb line,
right in our, in our sermon series.
That anything that's just slightly Ben, slightly off
from true north is gonna lead to horrible results one way
or the other way off from Right.
That's good. So we've looked at these words,
said we've looked at iniquity.
The last word that we'll look at
that the biblical authors use to describe
what we're talking about tonight is the word transgression.
So the Hebrew word that they use is pecha,
and the Greek word is Pima.
So pecha refers to the ways
that people violate the trust of others
as in the betrayal of a relationship.
So this plays out in multiple kinds
of relationships throughout scripture.
Um, it can be between persons, it could be between nations.
And if two nations are in a treaty with one another
and one nation breaks,
that treaty violates the terms of that treaty.
That nation would be said to, uh, paal with the other,
to break trust with the other party.
That's the word that it's used.
Transgression is that same word.
So this transgression
or breaking of relational trust can happen between humans.
We can peal with one another
and break trust with one another.
And we can also peal with God, break trust
between God and man.
Some ways that we see this played out in scripture is in
Hosea, the prophet accuses the Israelites
of Pesa transgression because of their worship of other gods
and violating the trust between Israel and Yahweh.
As that, that's transgression and another prophet.
In Amos, we see the prophet associates transgression
with its choice to mistreat or ignore the poor
and the vulnerable community, which is ultimately a betrayal
of breaking of trust of humanity
and honoring humans made in God's image.
So how does transgression
with our neighbor ultimately equate
to transgression with God?
How does betraying trust with our neighbor ultimately
equates to breaking trust with God?
Well, it doesn't it break the second
commander. Love your neighbor.
Love your neighbor. Yeah. Yeah. Oh God.
Love your neighbor. I'm gonna ask this in a
and uh, maybe frame this question with a story.
Right? So just recently,
a couple weeks ago in the sermon series, we looked at, um,
David sin, uh, against, uh, Uriah ahead type,
where he took Bathsheba, Uriah's wife slept with,
slept with Bashiva,
and then went to have Uriah, his friend killed.
Right? And when David is confessing that sin
before God, he says this, this phrase
to God in Psalm 51 says, I'm against you
and you only have I sinned.
But if you've just read that story, you're like, man, no,
David, you s sin against your right.
You sin against dash shiva.
But how David views it is those sins.
While yes, transgressions with Uriah, breaking trust
with Uriah, breaking trust with Ashima, he ultimately views
that as breaking trust with God, sinning against God.
So coming back to that question, how does that transgression
with our neighbor, breaking trust with our neighbor,
ultimately if waits up, breaking trust with God?
I think kind of how you saying earlier
that God is the creator and you just hurt
or, you know, destroyed something that he created.
I guess he tells us to love one another,
but it's also created all of us equally.
So, especially if you hurt someone
that's literally like taking someone's favorite item
that they work so hard to make
and just inspected it on the ground. Mm-hmm.
So
how else it's a disregard of that person,
whether it's the neighbor
or ultimately it's of God.
Mm-hmm. Because of all that she just said.
Thoughts on that
Two? I think it's, uh, first
John, he says, uh,
how can you say you love, uh, God?
And you can't see in the nature neighbor, you can't see.
So I think there's a correlation between it's easy to say,
well, I love God theoretically.
Yeah. But it's harder
to say I love a real concrete in your face.
It's sort of like, uh, we talked talking about the sin
of murder and the image of God.
Uh, God states that it's wrong
because man's amazing God's image.
So in some ways, I think similar in
transgressing the image of God.
Yeah,
Yeah, Yeah.
Similar language to what Jesus says too.
How he commands us is basically that whole, um,
saying of whenever you did this to the least
of these, you did it to me.
Right? Whenever you took care of the poor, clothed,
the naked, um, bound up the broken heart and the hurting,
whenever you did the least of those,
it's like you were doing it to me, God identifies
with his image bearers in that way.
So if we sin against one another
with sin against his image bearers
and transgress against others, God views that
as if you're doing it to him.
It elevates definitely the weight of our sin,
and especially sin in our relationships with one another.
It's not just hurting one another.
You're hurting that relationship with God
by hurting one another.
So hopefully these three sins
and understanding those a little bit further,
missing the mark, that it's bent and twisted and crooked,
and that it's breaking trust, those words to describe sin,
helps to fill out your understanding of what sin looks like.
So the next question that we have in, are all of us affected
by sin or all humans affected by sin?
I think we all will not to that,
but let's look at that, what that looks like.
There would be, uh, Romans five.
We're going to flip over there we
were, we were in Romans one.
So if you're still there, flip over a couple pages.
Romans five, we're gonna look at verses 12 to 14.
This is where our verse for the night comes from.
Paul writes here that
therefore just as sin came into the world through one man
and death through sin, and so death spread to all men,
because all sin for sin indeed was in the world
before the law was given.
But sin is not counted. Whether is no law, stay with me.
I know this can get confusing.
Yet death reigned from Adam to Moses,
even over those whose sinning was not like the transgression
of Adam, who was a type of the one to come.
So I, I understand this can be a bit difficult
to read both in the odd language that Paul is using,
and also it can be difficult to read in his content.
Paul's saying some pretty, um, radical things here.
He's saying, read that again, that death,
death spread to all men because all sin.
And he says that in relationship to talking about Adam's
specific sin.
So basically he's saying, because Adam sinned, all sinned.
And it's not, what it's not saying is that
because Adam sinned, all will sin.
While that is true, he's saying when Adam sinned
that one sin, it's as if we all sin, all
of humanity sin with Adam.
Essentially what Paul is explaining here is what we've come
to know as the doctrine of imputed or inherited sin.
So we're gonna look at this in two ways.
We're gonna talk about inherited guilt
and inherited corruption.
So inherited guilt is the, is the idea the fact
that we are all counted guilty because of Adam's sin.
So this idea that all men's sin means that God
considers all of us, all of us as humanity as having sinned.
When Adam disobeyed a little further on in
verses 18 and 19,
you see Paul elaborate on this a little bit more.
He says that by one man's disobedience,
many were made sinners because of one man's disobedience.
Many were made sinners.
So when Adam's sin, God basically considers all
who would descend from Adam as also being sinners.
So that is inherited guilt.
We'll talk about that in just
a little bit more in just a second.
But also wants to look at what inherited corruption.
So if we're taking inherited sin as one broad ca category,
we're looking at how that plays out as guilt and corruption.
So inherited corruption, say that we have a sinful nature
because of Adam's sin.
Sometimes you might hear this referred to as original sin.
Uh, it's basically the same idea.
It speaks to the fact that all humans are inherently born
with a fallen nature with sinful tendencies,
desires, and dispositions bent on rebelling against God
and his good order.
Essentially, it's why the world has a sin problem,
because we have in us this corrupt nature bent towards
sin rather than being bent towards righteousness.
Psalm 51, verse five, David describes this in himself
as God is revealing it to him, saying, behold,
I was brought forth in inequity.
That same word for being bent, twisted, corrupt.
He says, I was brought forth in inequity and in sin.
My mother concede me, essentially saying,
from the time I was born,
before I was even born, I was already bent,
twisted, and corrupted.
I didn't become twisted
and corrupted as I sinned to saying, as when I was born,
I was already sinful and twisted.
And what he's ultimately doing is describing that himself,
but also describing that
as the human condition in our natures.
We totally lack spiritual good before our God
and in our actions we are totally unable to do
spiritual good before God.
Even at our best efforts, we are unable incapable
of being good before God because of our corruption.
So this is a pretty difficult reality for us
to come to terms with, right?
And it's hard for us to accept, even in biblical circles.
It's hard for us to accept this,
especially if we've grown up in western American culture
where we tend to be very individualistic.
We like to think that our future positions are determined by
what we do, right?
It's that idea of like, I don't care what I was born into.
I can make a name for myself.
I can make a living for myself, whatever.
It's a name for myself.
And so we, we kind of want to reject this
and it, it hurts a little bit to accept,
but in a moment I'll, we'll talk about why that idea
of being so ruggedly individualistic is actually not a very
good thing for us.
And it might seem unfair,
but really this idea of imputation isn't
as foreign as we think.
I'll give you an example of this
that maybe we can all can somewhat relate to.
Um, does anyone hear a football fan?
American football family? I am Jacob is we're going to,
yeah, I know you guys all have fantasy football teams
on your phones right now.
Okay? So consider, what is it called?
If the offense is lined up, ready to run play,
the quarterback is behind series calling cadence.
And that slot receiver over here
jumps off the line. What do we call that?
False start. False start. False start, right?
False start. Every, all other 10 players,
11 players on the field.
The other 10 did not move,
but yet one over here, one receiver moves.
What does the referee do?
Penalize the whole team
Throws, throws the flag, right?
It's on the field. All starts call, does just
that one receiver have to move back five yards?
No, the entire team moves back, right? Change
That Because of one man's mistake.
All 11 have to move back with him.
So this is a very simple example,
but I'm, I'm using it to draw out the idea that this idea of
imputed consequences, imputed sin, is really not as,
as formed as we might think.
We don't, we have no problem accepting
that when it comes to football, right?
And it's the same idea by one man's sin, Adam.
All of humanity is counted as being on Adam's team.
And we all accept the penalty to the weight of that sin.
Now that's heavy. It's hard to reconcile with.
But there's also good news when it comes to imputation,
imputed consequences.
Because while it can be difficult when it comes to sin,
this reality, this existence
of the mutation brings overwhelming blessing when
Jesus applies it.
So read the rest of Romans five 15 through 19.
Is someone still there? Let's look at the rest of that.
Does someone read verses 15 through 19?
If the free gift does not like the T for as many died
to one man's trespass much more because grace of God
and the free gift by the grace of that one man, Jesus
Christ, abounded from amen.
And the free gift does not like the result
of the one man's sin
for the judgment following one trespass, but condemnation.
But the free gift following many trespasses
brought justification.
Or because one man's trespass death brain from that one man,
much more for those who receive the abundance of grace
in the pre righteousness brain in the life,
the one man Jesus Christ.
We could read that 10 times over and over again
and just worship Jesus more
and more each time we read it, right?
Because what he's saying there, remember we talked about how
our individualistic mindset isn't so good?
Well think about everything we talked about so far. So far.
How many of us have missed the mark?
How many of us have lived out some sort of broken
or twisted behavior?
How many of us have committed transgression
against our neighbors?
If we really want individual results
for our individual actions, we're all hopeless, right?
We're all completely guilty.
But the good news of invitation here is
that our eternal position of righteousness, it's not up
to us to earn, we're not capable of earning it,
but it's imputed to us in Christ Jesus, the new Adam.
So all, even though through the first Adam,
we all inherit sin, what's being offered to us
through Jesus is eternal, um,
sanctification, eternal glory, eternal redemption through
that man's righteousness.
Isaiah 53 6 reminds us
that all we like sheep have gone astray.
We have turned every one of us to his own way.
And the Lord Yahweh has laid on him Jesus, the iniquity,
that same word of us all that corrupted,
twisted result of our sins.
He has laid it on Jesus on our behalf.
So while you might wrestle with why
imputed sin is difficult, um, also understand
and remember that imputed righteousness
is far more glorious than the sin.
So we're gonna move forward here to our last section here
before we, we get into a little bit of discussion
and we're gonna look at the punishment, the results of sin.
So first question I'll ask is, does there have
to be a punishment for sin?
Yes. 'cause God is holding Yes. 'cause God is holding.
But why God's holy? Why must there be a punishment for sin?
Can't be the presence of sin.
Can't be in the presence of sin.
He's Infinitely wholly.
So the punishment must be infinite
to correspond with the infinite
Outrage. Yeah.
Gut his gut, his also gut his adjust
so he can just wash it away.
Just forgive God, affect just,
Yeah. Yeah.
It has to be just
Time. He
can be gracious and loving,
but he also is just, yeah, at the short of it,
God's righteousness demands it so that he can be glorified
in the university University's created.
So we're gonna look at the punishment.
We're gonna go through this a little, little quickly,
but we're gonna break down the punishment for sin, uh,
in five ways, five categories for how this breaks down.
But as we look at these, uh, we're not gonna just look at
what the punishment is, but we're also gonna look at
how Jesus endures this punishment for us.
So the first punishment that we see for sin is
that there's going to be suffering and hardship in life.
So going back to the curse in Genesis three,
after Adam's sin, we see God, um, say
that there will be a universal punishment
for sin in the fact that life is going to be a struggle
for all of humanity going forward.
We see in that curse
that this plays out in relational struggles
between the man and the woman.
Um, but we also see that it's just going
to be difficult to survive.
It says from the sweat of your brow, you're gonna,
you're gonna, um, produce fruit food
for the ground for you to survive.
Where if you think about the condition
before was a abundance, right?
And God was supplying everything There is going
to be difficulty, hardship in life.
It's just gonna be hard to live.
So my question there is how did Jesus
experience this punishment for sin and his earthly life?
Sorry,
Yes.
Ultimately pay paid that.
But how did he experience suffering and hardship and life
Experience lazarous and sw over it?
So experienced death. Yeah.
Loss. Yeah.
So he experienced, um, hunger,
feeling hunger, weariness.
He
Yeah. Yeah.
Just living as a human is hard. Right?
Betrayal. Betrayal. Yeah. He experienced betrayal,
But Jesus didn't have original sin. Right?
But he definitely experienced the punishments,
the consequences of sin.
Yes. No, he did not have original sin.
He was tempted. He was tempted. Yeah.
All the things that just make life hard, Jesus endure.
So this brings us to this second punishment for sin, is
that there will be physical pain and death.
So along with that hardship in life, God issued to Adam,
the penalty of death and decay as a result of his sin.
He says, for you are dust into dust, you shall return.
Let's talk about physical pain and death.
How did Jesus experience physical pain
and death for sin and his crucifixion?
Torture that he endured before physical? Yeah.
Yeah. The torture that he endured going to the paint
or going to the cross wasn't a quick thing for sure.
So the spiritual pain of taking on the sin of the world
became, yeah.
Yeah, that's a good one.
And we'll talk a little bit more of that.
The, just the physical pain endure to,
to think about the flogging
or having to drag his cross up a hill, being nailed
to it, hanging there, struggling for breath,
and then ultimately experiencing death as a human.
Uh, Jesus absolutely endured physical pain
and death as a punishment for sin.
Taking that on. The third punishment we see is
psychological pain and bearing the guilt of sin.
So, uh, going back to Genesis, it says, then the eyes
of both were opened and they knew that they were naked.
Um, all Christians have experienced this sense
of shameful exposure.
When we sin and we know that we've done wrong, um,
the Holy Spirit convicts us of that, right?
But there's a consequence, there's a punishment for sin.
That's just knowing this bitter sense
that we're we're not right.
That something is not right,
and that we're separated from that.
It's this psychological pain and shame. Guilt of sin.
So consider for a moment with me, what,
what this must have been like for Jesus to endure.
So we have Jesus who's perfectly holy
and blameless, to suddenly have the full guilt
of all humanity's sin suddenly be thrust upon him.
All that he hated most sin.
Hmm. Was suddenly poured fully out on him,
having never experienced guilt for sin.
Something he never experienced in his life.
Leading up to that, his eternity leading up to that,
to suddenly dealing with bearing the weight of all sin
or that guilt being put on his shoulders.
That must have been crushing to experience as he was there.
The fourth punishment moving forward is
what you were referring to,
the spiritual pain of abandonment.
So in the garden, Adam
and Eve hid, when they sinned, they hid from one another.
They were, remember going back to our conversation
of being alone, being bad.
They hid from one another,
but they also hid from the presence of the Lord God.
So as a result of sin, fellowship between God and man,
and between man and fellow, man is broken, broken.
How do you think that Jesus experienced this penalty
for sin and his death?
Hear a lot about Peter, you know, away from Christ.
I don't know for sure, but I'm guessing all
the bosses were running around scared
and thinking this guy's phony
and looking to take care of themselves.
It says they all fox.
It wasn't just separation from his fellow man, his neighbor,
his friends, but he experienced his spiritual abandon.
My God, my God, why have you forsaken me?
And then finally we'll end here.
The last punishment for sin is the wrath of God.
So finally, the holiness
and justice of God requires that every single sin be paid
for sin being by its very nature opposed the existence
and glory of God demands a righteous
and a holy fury against it from the God
who created all things.
It's what Hebrews talks about as its fearful thing
to fall into the hands of the living God.
So we're gonna end before Brad comes up
and leads us into discussion.
And I want us to consider about what it actually means.
That Jesus bore all the wrath
of the Father against our sins while in the cross,
how excruciating it must have been as we as wave
after wave of God's intense anger against sin
came crashing down on it.
I try to think about that.
I'm like, who could possibly bear that?
None of us do, right?
None of us could bear the wrath,
the full on unfiltered wrath of God on sin, all sin.
And yet Jesus does.
So I want us to think about that
and affect the way that they view his last moments
of Jesus on the cross.
When he's sitting there and he finally says it is finished.
He agrees at his last
because he's just finished enduring the full wrath of God
on him for all sin.
And that's what he endured upon.
So those are the punishments of sin results.
So I'm gonna stop there, Brad,
I'm invite you to come on here.
Thank you Chris.
Uh, you live me in a bad spot to follow that.
So, um, I want to touch a ladder note.
I love true false questions. I love them.
You know why I have at least 50%
chance to get it right, better than multiple choice?
'cause then it goes down to 25.
And if I have to, you know, write an answer,
it goes to zero usually.
So I love true false questions
and uh, I was going to just
give out a whole bunch of true false questions tonight
to get us thinking about more about
the doctrine of sin, the consequences of sin.
And that just didn't seem perfect.
Such as is it sinful to gamble on sports?
Is Satan your greatest enemy
or is it a So I'm not gonna do those,
but I did want to go deeper.
I I did want to make it a lot more
personal instead of just trying it as a true false Yes.
Think about, you don't have to say who it is,
but you can think about the happiest,
the most joyful Christian that you know.
Why are they that way, way, or why were they
Maybe a better question.
Would somebody say that you were the most
happiest and joyful Christian family?
And so I say all that to, to get down to
what we're talking about today.
The greatest, the
greatest thing in the world is to be a Christian.
The greatest thing in the world is to be saved.
And so when he just went through those five things
and I get lower and lower and lower and lower
and shorter, you might see,
do I enjoy my Christian Hood?
Do I do I love my salvation?
Psalm 74, for those
who love their salvation, do we do that?
Do they see it on your face and in your life?
Not just some giddy, uh, you know,
trite, oh praise God Anyway, kind of person,
but true joy despite
horrible things that may happen in your life.
Lemme ask you this. How often
do you think about your salvation?
Do you think about it every day,
once a week, Sundays
or supper Easter?
If you think about the, the happiest, most joyful Christian
that you know, could it be
that they knew the lost in, in their support,
that he just, and they knew it down
to their core
and down to their Bones.
They knew their lostness
and their depravity to such an extent
that it translated into what Chris just said, I'm
so happy to be saved.
Can you believe it?
It's unbelievable.
I don't think, I mean, it's hard.
We all put on a pretty good front,
all look pretty put together.
But it's a true joy.
And it's a true, you know, going back
to Thanksgiving next week, gratitude
and thankfulness that all my word, I'm supposed to be dead.
I have no chance without him. None. Zero.
And yet he lets me be in his family.
Am I not happier in my salvation
because I'm noth in my sin?
Chris already said it.
Do we treasure Christ above all?
Do I love God more than I love Brenda?
Do I more than you might love your kids
more than you love yourself?
And all the things that that entails.
Why is it that many of us
have a difficult time seeing us, seeing ourselves
as totally depraved?
What, why do we, I'm just asking
why do we not talk about that more?
Any thoughts?
I think it's like a spectrum. I think there's a lot people
that see themselves as maybe better than other people.
And like that is a sin.
But then there's also plenty of people
that have such like low self-confidence that,
that they're not good enough
and matter what they do, they're never
and you
beautiful creation from God.
And that is, that's a blessing.
How about our, um, our witnessing and our evangelism?
How does our view of the total depravity
of man affect that?
Because I think it should.
'cause if I, if I look at the person
that bros across the counter from me or in the drive through
and I see them as, oh my word,
they're not gonna make it without him.
Like there's no hope.
What does that, does that stir anything up in me?
You know, does it, does it cause me to say, Hey, do you go
to church anywhere or have you ever heard of God?
Or how are you and God or just striking up a conversation
and yet it's just not cool, right? And it's hard
And You get embarrassed
and uncomfortable,
Right? I think too, and
certain people
and even certain communities, it's sort of easy
to see the brokenness in the world
or sort of the wrong on display.
But I think like a place like Edmond where
we're good at kind of putting on a face
and there's more prosperity
and things like that, it's easy for people
to feel like, well I don't need that.
You know, make my life not be better than yours is. Right?
Or I'm healthier than you are.
And, but the doctrine of sin teaches us that we're all,
we all need a savior, right?
And it doesn't matter how bad it is
or it's not, it's not circumstantial.
It's a set thing.
Sometimes the hardest people to reach are people
who have it all together and don't have any needs.
And so I, I want to just, um,
my wife knows I sit in depravity quite a bit.
I sit in it a lot, maybe to a fold,
but it sure makes me appreciate
much more than I ever have
that I get to be with him.
That I get to be in his presence.
I get to be in his presence right now.
It's not like, Hey, I get to go to heaven someday. I do.
I get to enjoy him right now.
And you know, we should be doing cartwheels.
You really should. Like, you should be weird.
You should be very strange.
It's like, I don't like to be around him
'cause he's just weird smiling all the time.
Happy, wanting to talk about God.
Yeah, we should, we should.
Last question. I'm,
I'm preaching to myself.
I'm not asking you to answer any questions.
I'm just talking to myself.
Why will I be happy when I enter heaven?
I Think that
what's the chief reason
that I'm so happy?
Alright, Brett, Chris,
Hey, uh, we, we are out of time.
It's what you guys need to run, go for it.
What I'd like to do is
For everybody to line up over here, we're bring car
all the way across if you're able,
if you're able. No,
Uh, I thought let's do this.
Let's, everybody probably knows it.
Um, a song that keeps coming to mind.
I had other ones, but we're out of time.
Um, anybody know John Newton?
Is John Newton was, I should say is, uh,
well he was a, before he wrote the song, amazing Grace.
He was the captain of the slave ship
and he was by his own account, a terrible individual.
And so anyway, he got, he met Christ, changed his life.
And uh, he wrote the song Amazing Grace that we all sang.
And he famously said, uh, on his, on his deathbed,
I think he lost his eyesight.
And uh, he was losing his mind, uh, just in old age.
And he was fond of saying, uh, you know, I don't remember
what I would say it exactly, but, um, he said,
there's one thing I remember
and it's that I am a, um, I remember way He said,
I'm a terrible sinner and God is a great savior
and Christ is a great savior and I'm, I'm a great sinner
and Christ is a great savior.
And anyway, so he wrote these words,
I want to sing the first line.
You gotta stand up, join, you know it, sing it
so you know, listen to me.
Alright. Amazing.
Sweet. The sounding saved
love, like meaning
I was, was lost.
But Now I found
Was My,
but now I see.
What do we think for the words of this song
that we sing easily?
Like sometimes the words don't even strike us
as they should, but as we think about John Newton,
this great center who met this great savior, we're reminded
of our own story.
Maybe by some measure we're not that bad,
or maybe by others we're worse.
But at the end of the day, that is the gospel truth
we take away, is that we are great sinners
and we live in a world full of great sin
and wrecked by the fall of, yet you are great savior
and you are overcoming the world.
And Lord, we look to you, we love you,
and we thank you indeed as bread.
So we thank you for your salvation and Christ holy name.
Amen. Alright, thank you. Well done.